und damit kommen wir aber jetzt erstmal
zu ihrem Thema was auch eins ist was
wirklich die Nation auch spaltet kann
man ganz klar sagen also tut mir Leid
über die Heftigkeit der Diskussion aber
das ist einfach wichtig weil es man muss
wenn man wissenschaftlich argumentiert
von vorne beginnen von der Basis wenn
die nicht stimmt und wir hatten keine
Überbelegung wir hatten keine Probleme
nee das ist Fakt und jetzt und deswegen
ist es von vornherein ein problematisch
einen Impfstoff der experimentell ist
und eine große medizinische Leistung
mit einer bedingten Zulassung dann
loszulassen und jetzt müssen wir mal die
bedingte Zulassung sich anschauen darf
EU-Ebene da steht drin das muss ganz
engmaschig kontrolliert werden für die
Nationalstaaten müssen an die EU die
Daten engmaschig liefern das macht die
Bundesregierung überhaupt nicht sie
lehnt das gerecht ab und es muss im
Beipackzettel und jedem Patienten und
jede medizinisch Personal ganz klar
gemacht werden es handelt sich um eine
bedingte Zulassung sprich die die
Zulassungsstudien sind nicht
abgeschlossen und wenn man das bedenkt
und wenn man die Warnungen bedenkt die
dann auch mit den Impfnebenwirkungen
schon früh geäußert wurden und dann
sieht was jetzt los ist ich habe täglich
Patienten mit schweren Nebenwirkungen
ich gebe zu das ist selektiv weil
natürlich die Leute extra deswegen auch
wissen dass ich ihnen zuhöre weil sie
werden nämlich von ihren Ärzten nicht
ernst genommen und das sind heute ich
füge kein Komma zu ein junger Mann 20
Jahre alt ja nach der ersten Impfung
schlecht geschlafen hat der Arz deutlich
verschreib mal ein berührungsmittel
zweite Impfung vier Wochen später
schwerste Augenprobleme er hat eine
Ausbildung angefangen zum Fahrlehrer
muss der abbrechen dann ging das zwei
Monate später los mit mit Schwäche des
Arms danach einigen Monaten konnte nicht
mehr richtig laufen der rennt von ponsus
zu Pilatus kriegt einen Termin in der
neuromuskulären Ambulanz im dezember
2022 kein Arzt nimmt ihn ernst und das
ist kein Einzelfall ich tausche mich aus
mit mit Ärzten die sich dem Thema öffnen
und die erleben das genau das gleiche
und wir haben inzwischen ja auch weil
Deutschland keine vernünftige
Wissenschaft hinkriegt aber muss sagen
die Studie von Herrn mattes ist nun mal
das einzige was mir einigermaßen
vernünftig haben und da kommt eine Zahl
heraus die international ja auch
bestätigt ist von 0,8% pro Impfung
schwere Nebenwirkungen Nebenwirkungen
hat er gesagt aber nicht verstanden
schweren eben wirken gesagt ja er hat
sie gesagt aber sind keine schweren
Nebenwirkungen
er hat definiert mit Arztbesuch mehrere
Tage krank und so weiter ich kenne ich
habe seit 30 Jahren impfig aber ich habe
sowas noch nie erlebt nur bei der
corona-impfung gibt es nicht bei jeder
Impfung impfnebenwirkung die eingepreist
aber wir haben jetzt schon wir haben
jetzt schon bei den bei der Zahl von
Paul ehrlichen zu die nur gemeldeziffern
haben wir 0,02 aber das sind in
Gesamtzahlen so viel dass jedes normal
zugelassene Medikament eigentlich schon
die Zulassung aber wir haben den Faktor
und 70 inzwischen und ich kann wirklich
nur in die Verantwortung an an den
appellieren leute ihr müsst die
Zulassung ruhen lassen um die eminenten
Sicherheitsfragen zu klären und nochmal
Deutschland kommt zu einer Pflicht nicht
hinterher selbst im
Infektionsschutzgesetz steht dass die
kassenärztliche Vereinigungen die die
impfdaten liefern müssen sie tun es
nicht so jetzt wird diese Leute darf man
Leute werden
das ist die Zulassungsstudien sind nicht
sind längst abgeschlossen und die
bedingte Zulassung ist darauf
zurückzuführen dass man die
Zulassungsstudien parallel zur Zulassung
bereits begleitet was ungewöhnlich Ende
das zweite es sind inzwischen 12
Milliarden Impfdosen weltweit vergeben
worden wo sind die vielen Nebenwirkungen
das möchte ich wirklich mal wissen
drittens glauben Sie denn dass alle
Ärzte ihre Kollegen meine Kollegen die
Leute immer alle nicht ernst nehmen nein
es gibt bestimmte Ärzte die also
gewisses Charisma darin haben solche
Dinge anzuziehen und die Menschen
besonders ernst zu nehmen schließlich
die Impfstudie von Herrn mattes die ist
gar nicht abgeschlossen die Charité ist
im Höchstmaß entsetzt darüber und das
ist entspricht widerspricht jedem
wissenschaftlichen Standard dass man
eine Studie die noch gar nicht
abgeschlossen geschweige denn
ausgewertet ist bereits publizistische
in der Frage um die Impfpflicht benutzt
und damit der Zug Gefahr in Verzug
natürlich also Gefahr im Verzug wie
impfen immer noch täglich mehrere zig
bis 100.000 Menschen dann als die als
die Infektionszahlen höher waren und wir
sehen eben nicht diese Nebenwirkungen im
Bereich der seriösen wissenschaftlichen
Leiter eines impfzentrums gesprochen der
hat der hat wegen Impfzentrum geleitet
nach der ersten Impfung Anstieg der
Leberenzyme hat sich schlecht gefühlt
Ferritin hoch runter zweite Impfung
geworden Frank oder gibt es wirklich die
Breite der Fälle und die Kausalität
ich bin sehr gut ich bin sehr gut
vernetzt mit mit wirklich führenden
Epidemiologen die nichts zu melden haben
in dieser ganzen grünen Diskussion zum
Beispiel Mathias Schrappe das ist Gerd
antes und die Sagen von Anfang an wir
haben überhaupt keine Erfassung wir
lassen die Leute blind ins Messer laufen
wir kümmern uns überhaupt nicht um
irgendwelche hatten Datenerhebungen und
wenn es dann mattes zu diskreditieren
der als erster jetzt mal versucht da
irgendwie Licht ins Dunkel zu bringen
bin ich ein starkes Stück wo sind
bitteschön die Untersuchungen gezeichnet
dass diese diese impfnebenwirkung
marginal sind also sehr viel uns darüber
einig dass es nicht wissenschaftlicher
Standard ist eine Studie die noch nicht
abgeschlossen ist und die noch gar nicht
ausgewertet worden ist rein empirisch
irgendwie irgendwas dazu zu sagen und
eine Zahl zu konstruieren wie 0,8 warten
wir doch mal ab was rauskommt wenn diese
Studie zu Ende ist und wenn sie
ausgewachsen und Sie müssen darüber
hinaus auch wissen das ist keine Studie
kein sogenanntes randomisiertes
prospektive Untersuchung sondern das ist
der Ergebnis bitte an Menschen sich zu
melden ob sie impfen nehmen
diese Verdacht aber wir haben dich schon
wir haben dich nur nicht fertig und noch
nicht ausgewertet ich habe nämlich da
auch einen direkt eine Frage an sehr
Gefahr und zwar haben sie denn als
Bürger Bedenken gehabt oder haben sie
sich impfen lassen wie stehen sie denn
zu den nehmen also ich bin ein treuer
deutsche Staatsbürger meine Eltern sind
auch uralt deutsche von daher bin ich
natürlich wie ist der Befehl verlangt
dreimal impfen gegangen habe mich auch
pusten lassen entgegen der Empfehlung
von Freunden die Ärzte sind und habe
jetzt alles getan und mein
amerikanischen Freunden von denen ich
viele habe die mich geraten haben macht
das nicht und habe da ich wohl Corona
bekommen so viel dazu ich lasse mich
also in Zukunft nicht mehr impfen weil
in der Abwägung der impfrisiken gegen
die Tatsache durch den Corona trotz
Impfung bekommen habe hat mich irgendwie
in meinem Inneren etwas aufgewühlt aber
ich möchte eigentlich zwei andere Fragen
stellen die ich heute morgen schon mir
überlegt hatte im Bettchen noch dann ist
mir nicht froh dass darf und zwar ist
die eine Frage ist ich bin nie klar
geworden über Jahre höre ich den so
objektiven Deutschlandfunk öffentlich
rechtlichen Rundfunk nicht und will ich
jeden morgen bekomme ich meine Lesung
und unter anderem waren über Monate
wieder Wehrmachtsbericht früher waren
die Berichte über die coronazeit und
dann hörte ich immer mit und an Corona
ja eigentlich verstorben was ist denn
mit und was ist denn an entweder Hardter
Corona oder ist er ein mit Corona oder
an was gestorben sie haben eben die
wissen bemüht wie wollen Sie denn zu
klaren Ergebnissen kommen an oder mit
gestorben wir
können nicht jeden Patienten der einen
oder mit Corona stirbt obduzieren das
heißt so schön dass wir mal es gibt aber
Untersuchungen die das ganz klar
beweisen und zwar gibt es zum Beispiel
im Bereich der Universitätsklinik
Hamburg großer Püschel und andere haben
eine Studie gemacht an tausend in
Hamburg gestorbenen Menschen zu 85
Prozent sind die an Corona die wären zu
dem Zeitpunkt nicht gestorben wenn sie
nicht Corona gehabt hätten das natürlich
diese Menschen auch andere Erkrankungen
haben das ist eine andere Kiste aber wir
sind doch nicht so zynisch dass wir
sagen also du hast jetzt eh schon eine
andere Erkrankung deswegen stirbt man
bevor sie so sondern
es kommt auf den Kontext an es kommt auf
den Kontext an erstens nein ich habe
da musst du meine Frage noch stellen die
mich bewegen
also die Frage ist wieso die haben
gesprochen von den Zuständen auf den
Station ich habe eine sehr gute Bekannte
diese OP also Schwester in der Charité
auf einer Intensivstation und wissen Sie
was mich umgehauen hat die lässt sich
nicht impfen wie haben wir eine
Situation dass die die unmittelbar
konfrontiert sind mit dieser Heimsuchung
des Herrn dass diese Leute die nun
wirklich zittern
Mitarbeiter und da hat man in Italien
sehr klare Regel gefunden hat diesen
Menschen hat diese Menschen in andere
Bereiche versetzt oder ihnen das
Arbeitsverhältnis
haben weitergearbeitet heute haben sich
im heute als wieder da nämlich
irgendwann die Vernunft und der Verstand
ein und das lassen sie mich ja aber
Vernunft
beugt warum gerade in dem Personenkreis
ja ich hatte heute eine Schwester
sagt sie sieht das eben vermehrt junge
die er nie von Kurve 19 bedroht sind das
ist ja auch das Problem wenn wir bei der
Impfung über die Risikogruppen sprechen
dann können wir darüber sprechen aber
doch nicht bitte die überhaupt nicht von
kurvig 19 bedroht bedroht sind da müssen
wir doch jetzt stoppen und diese
Schwester hat jetzt gekündigt er sagt
sie macht das nicht mehr mit und wir
müssen einfach auch mal die Gesamtzahlen
die Gesamtzahlen sehen wir haben vor
Übersterblichkeit gesprochen da kann man
natürlich lange diskutieren wie
ermittelt man Übersterblichkeit aber
wenn Sie das prozentual nehmen dann
sehen sie dass 2020 im Vergleich zu den
einzeljahren in eher ein günstiges
Sterbejahr war muss man sagen 2021
jedoch im zweiten Jahreshälfte ging das
los und es betrifft die jüngeren
Jahrgänge das sind Fakten das kann ich
Ihnen auch leicht belegen also wir haben
hier kein übersterblichkeitsproblem
gehabt 2020 aber wir fangen mit 2021
zwar die Jahreshefte damit an bei
jüngeren die und da ist ich sage nicht
dass das die Impfung ist aber da hat die
Kampagne angefangen bei den Jüngeren und
es müssen wir versuchen und wenn Herr
mattes diese Meldungen gibt dann macht
er nicht weil er jetzt sagt das ist die
fertige Studie sondern sagt es ist
Gefahr in Verzug wir müssen das Thema
jetzt diskutieren und ich appelliere an
alle die irgendwie Verantwortung tragen
bitte machen Sie nicht so weiter wir
bevor wir nicht wirklich die Sache
sauber untersucht haben können wir nicht
wieder diese Panik schüren Leute in die
Impfung brauchen
nach allen seriösen Kriterien muss die
bedingte Zulassung gestoppt werden und
die Sicherheitsfragen geklärt werden das
Impfen
die Seriosität der Kriterien
gegen die gesamte seriöse Wissenschaft
nein nein nein nein
gerade die wichtigste Zahl genannt und
sie haben sie nicht gekannt das
disqualifiziert sie beide muss ich in
ganz klar sagen ja wahrscheinlich wir
nehmen das demütlich hin dass sie uns
dann ja
zwei Prozent in Krankenhäusern bereits
verimpft oder von Anfang an den nicht
verimpft ich habe ihn bei Patienten in
der Risikogruppe anfangs verimpft und
dann habe ich mich da näher mit befasst
und habe mich dann entschlossen nicht
mehr zu impfen weil ich kann dies nicht
verantworten und ich habe auch heute
erlebt dass die gerne viele viele
Kollegen leider den Leuten nicht gesagt
haben dass es eine bedingte Zulassung
ist und damit nicht regulär und die
Zulassungsstudie haben und komme 2023
ist
2023 abgeschlossen
die jeder ausfüllen muss wenn er geimpft
wird in den der Patient darüber
aufgeklärt wird und sogar unterschreiben
muss dass er das weiß also sie haben das
doch selber bei ihren Patienten
hoffentlich gemacht weil wir haben hier
für diese Information geschrieben ich
habe die eine halbe Stunde aufgeklärt
und sehr gut und im Impfzentrum waren
trotzdem impfen lassen ja und das ist ja
das was geholfen hat bei 1.7 wir haben
heute bei 1700 auf der Spitze der
letzten Welle bei 1700 inzidenz-rate
einer irre hohen inzidenz-reise haben
wir zu haben wir doch weniger weniger
Tote gehabt als wir bei 150 Inzidenzrate
vor dem Jahr davor gehabt sie haben das
21 mehr Tote Impfung sie haben 2021
Ausdruck der Impfung und nicht
ausdrucken wir können über die
religiösen wir können wir haben 83 Jahre
Durchschnittsalter wir können über wir
können über die Risikogruppen sprechen
aber was unterhalb der Risikogruppen
abläuft halte ich für eine Fehlleistung
die können sich als die größte seit
Bestehen der Bundes
fühlen ja sie als Steuerzahler dürfen
gleich Ihre Frage stellen die sie schon
angemeldet haben Herr Gastro wir geben
eine ganz kurz Unterbrechung und dann
wieder zurück